foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm coming with you
[Music]
did you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them
Hello friends my name is Naz Perez and
you're watching the big ticket interview
for probably the pinkest movie you'll
ever see and that is Barbie I am so
excited to talk to all you guys about
this movie as I was driving over here I
was thinking about like how Barbie has
always had so much riding on her tiny
shoulders you know she was like this
blank canvas that we would project our
hopes and dreams onto and she was just
like a best friend to so many people
like was and still is she was my best
friend I hated humans growing up that's
what you were thinking about in the car
that's what I was thinking about in the
car right over here so that's why I
think that the world is just so excited
right now you can feel the momentum and
the energy that there is for this movie
because For the First Time in 64 years
we finally get to meet Barbie in real
life on the big screen because of this
movie um and there she is it doesn't
disappoint and our president Bobby and
our president and now we and Bobby and
our favorite and human Emma favorite
human ever I can't wait to dig into all
this but Margo I've been so lucky to
have gotten to interview you like multi
times and you've played such badass
women from Tanya Harding to Harley Quinn
so I was literally stunned when I heard
you say they're never going to let us
make this when you read the script now
the tickets are on sale can you tell us
why you thought that
um
the script is the script was when I read
it I I thought exactly I was like this
is genius and they're never going to let
us make it what a shame this is all
going to go to waste just because I
think it's a little more it's not just
that the movie is unexpected I think
it's like Greta kind of pushes it in
directions that I didn't think they
would let us go in and I think a big
part of that was kind of acknowledging
the things that people find problematic
about Bobby as well as the things that
people love about Bobby and to be able
to do both whilst also kind of having a
relevant conversation about where the
world is at today and then also be
acknowledging like this long 60 plus
year history it's just a lot of things
to do at once and she does it so deftly
and ultimately the whole experience is
still fun like it's just so fun and
weirdly emotional and at the end of it
all you're not even really thinking
about a doll you're thinking about what
it means to be alive in the world and it
gets it gets unexpectedly deep
um the reason I didn't think they'd let
us make it honestly is because the
Mattel CEO is like what a main character
Mattel itself is a character and I just
thought they're never going to agree to
this and then there was a lot of jokes
in there that I was like they're not
gonna let us get away with that but at
least
The Genius of it like I'm I did not grow
up with a strong feeling about Barbie
you know I didn't necessarily feel you
know like it resonated with me I didn't
feel like I belonged in the Barbie world
the Barbie universe and when I heard
that you know when Greta set wanted me
to read the script I said yes of course
because it's Greta and it's Margot and
they're so smart and so interesting with
Incredible point of views and that's why
I said yes to like reading it but by the
time I was done with the script Greta
and Noah because she wrote it with her
partner they they they took Barbie and
they addressed so many of the the
positives and the Not So positives of
like what she's meant in culture how she
started as a revolution But as time went
on not so much like how do we bring
Barbie into the 21st century and make
her relevant the standard of beauty and
aspiration and the icon of a woman how
do we make that relevant to girls today
who did not grow up seeing them
I love that you say that because I don't
know if you guys felt this way but I
felt like in movies growing up a lot of
the messaging I got was the the cool
girl with pretty clothes was always like
dumb and mean it was almost like yeah
because she was girly she was excluded
from being smart and driven and I love
that you mentioned like how Barbie was
just represented and how people thought
of her because Barbie was used as a
negative connotation back in the day
people would say oh she's such a Barbie
but there's a part of me that feels like
after this movie people are going to be
saying he's such a Ken yeah so I want to
know I want to ask all of you right now
what is a Ken how does one spot a can
that's so funny because when we were
like in prep for this movie
two of our wonderful producers one of
whom is also my husband when David and
Tom would like start talking about like
Bitcoin or something like Greta and I'd
be like they're being such cans they
talk about golf we're like stop being
Kens so it's hard to Define what makes a
can but it can also be they can also be
big can energy and that's a good thing
whereas Ryan says
it's not something you can Define it's
just something you can sense and you
know it yeah you can just feel it yeah
how do you guys spot a can
um I think a Ken for me is just kind of
there you know I think it can is a great
accessory but that's what I loved about
you know bretta's imagining of of Barbie
is that the Ken's are just supplemental
characters to these Barbies while
Barbies can do everything kids are there
to kind of support and don't necessarily
have their own story and I think
um that's not necessarily a negative
thing I think it's it's incredibly
strong for men to be in supportive roles
and to support the greatness that is
women slash Barbie yeah
yeah
I mean I think I think it's like it's
like when I read the script I was like I
knew I've I actually went to college
with Greta you guys so oh yeah I know
that she's like I knew that even before
and yeah do comedy shows with Greta girl
I did actually which is so full circle I
actually did
um so I knew like how brilliant she was
and when I heard she was doing the
Barbie movie I was like what is this
gonna be and but I knew it was going to
be something and then I read it and I
was like
about sort of about how like gender
roles deny people half their humanity
and how like
we need to just like be ourselves and
it's like a very
powerful message and so like
I spotted Ken it's just like everyone's
everyone's themselves you know yeah you
know everything about that in the car
okay
my favorite I can't wait to meet the
Ken's in this movie I loved Ken and my
favorite scene in the trailer is when
the kids are having a beach off Issa as
president Barbie what are the laws of
Barbie land what are the rules of a
beach off the rules of a beach are
um are
that you know you gotta just let the
kids go at it and kind of Define it
um let them Beach it all out there are
no beaches and beaches all beach-offs
um I think that
yeah I think you should ask Kenneth
honestly because I was um the president
was a little too busy to deal with that
in particular what are the biggest
issues that President Barbie's facing
right now you know Barbie line is
perfect so it's really just maintaining
the order of perfection
um Compliments are absolutely essential
we dance parties dance parties lots of
words yeah every 90 minutes I love your
Barbie Friends words of affirmation
constantly
um everything was you know universally
free universally free education
Healthcare everything signed into law
school are you taking any more citizens
um
hope this interview goes well no I'm
just kidding uh anyways I can't wait to
see all of Barbie land the sets just
look insane can't wait to see more
president Barbie ESO you just you are
President Barbie to me and like your
scenes and insecure and everything
you've said to yourself in the mirror is
just I mean it's inspired so many people
to do the same so I'm so happy you're
president Barbie I am eagerly as happy
that you are weird Barbie your
involvement in this movie okay it's just
the coolest yeah you're welcome and I
know that it's weird Barbie that
actually encourages Barbie to go out
into the real world but when I was
thinking of your character in the car I
was thinking about how we used to do
really weird stuff with our Barbies like
sometimes playing with Barbies is like
private time yeah like I would like make
them kids cut their hair if you played
with Barbies growing up what is the
weirdest thing you did
um I didn't but I witnessed my sister
and her friends do some stuff with those
Barbies and I think we all did and
um they're just it's it's just it's it's
imagination and it's a way of
um expressing your
innermost desires um and things that
you're exploring about yourself in the
world and it's like a it's a very it's a
good tool for children to have
it was like a total of aggression too
like my sister had a My Size Barbie and
I don't know what it was but because
maybe it was like close to our size we
beat that Barbie I don't know what it is
it's like my size My Size Barbie was
like a big yeah it's like a literal your
size Barbie and it was just like instead
of a small I know that existed do you
think she was lonely because she had no
friends she said no friends that's like
everybody else was a miniature and then
it was like more so it's Barbie I love
that you would use it as a Russian we're
so weird as humans uh speaking of you
know it's so weird that's something we
said at the beginning by the way we're
like I think it was you me and Greta
like doing rehearsal one day and we're
like isn't it so crazy that he like
humans are just so weird they made a
doll and then they got mad at the dog
we're not going oh here's the things
that we should do better in the world
we're kind of like you're doing this
wrong and you're doing this wrong and
you're doing this wrong it's a doll it's
a plastic doll and when made it but it's
not outload it's adults fault yeah no
we're rude as humans America I'm so
excited you're playing a human in this
because to me you are so human you're so
grounded in every role that you're in so
I think that that's really fun I can't
wait to see how humans and Barbies
interact in this movie and I really just
can't wait to see Barbie in the real
world in 2015 Barbie was the doll was
given a flat foot and adjustable ankles
but until then she had an arched foot
and the arched foot scene in the trailer
sent the internet Ablaze so I feel it is
my duty on behalf of Chrissy Teigen and
Society at large to ask you Margot about
that arched foot scene were those your
feet how many takes and were you propped
onto something tell us it was all
probably about
eight takes wasn't that many
um they on my feet I walked up we had
little sticky bits on the floor for the
like double-sided tape for the shoes so
they wouldn't
come off so that I could get my feet out
of them and I was holding on to like a
bar but that's it I wasn't like a
harness or anything like that I just
like walked up kind of held onto the bar
above camera
wow yeah and you are a dancer right I
did ballet when I was a kid
but I I I hate it I I always try and do
my own inserts like I don't like when I
watch a movie and I know it's not mine I
hate that swim I always say the director
like please let me do all my own things
I don't I don't like it knowing that I
didn't do it I also I I love that you
said that because I've talked to you
before about movement and I know that
sometimes you Channel animals for
different roles we talked about Nelly
being an octopus what did you Channel
plastic you know what the animals just
weren't helpful when I was prepping
Barbie I tried and and it just wasn't
wasn't going anywhere so I used
archetypes instead that was helpful I
love that yeah that scene was so insane
that I was reading that searches for
fluffy mules actually went up 115 and I
bring that up because Barbie in fashion
are just so inextricably linked like
clothes such an important part to how we
experience Barbie and put her in like
different roles I have friends that made
different clothes for their Barbie what
is your most favorite thing that you
wore in this movie and if it was in the
dance scene I would love to hear more
about that too
I will say I got to wear this dress that
was sort of inspired by like what would
happen if you put your Barbie in a baby
doll dress like if you stole a dress
from one of your like baby dolls from
the 18th century and put it on a Barbie
and then cut your Barbie's hair and Drew
on it and I was like I would wear this
every day I love this dress
I love the the marker on your face too I
can't wait to like see it in the movie
and some epic boots
and symmetric boots yes that sounds
pretty epic
um without going too deep into what
happens I mean the costume designer was
phenomenal and anytime I got to wear
something from a particular era but
there was this Cowboy outfit that I
actually rocked with that I was like oh
these are like some nice little coochie
Cutters that I would wear in real life
so Barbie was really fashionable
um so yeah that little cowboy cowgirl
outfit yeah I kind of like doing this
like I liked it sure is when the Bobbies
are trying to appeal to the Ken's for
some sort of plan that we won't get into
but
yeah I liked it too I felt really cute
in that outfit I was like I'm
to wear so many great outfits I think
one of my favorites just because it's
like so precious and high maintenance
and like funny is uh when when I'm kind
of returning to Barbie land from The
Real World and I have like a full
matching like poofy skirt with the
jacket and the thing underneath with the
bow and a hat and the Hat's got a bow
and she's got these cute little shoes on
it's just so much and and then she has
like a massive tantrum and it's just so
ridiculous and then by the end she's
like totally deflated and the jackets
off and the shoes are gone and she's
just like a a puddle on the floor
I can't wait to see the looks in this
movie The sets like everything is just
so good
um before I leave I wanted to ask you
guys one more question
Barbie historically has really been the
vehicle that we've been able to imagine
ourselves in different roles right
whether that be like princess or
president and when the movie posters for
this came out people connected to them
on a visceral level putting themselves
in the Barbie poster labeling themselves
as a certain type of Barbie
personally I would like to ask all four
of you what Barbie do you see yourself
as right now personally in this phase in
your life I think I've the bub I was
very like do it all Bobby like I can do
this and this and like multitasking was
such like a asset and now I'm kind of
like do it well Bobby like I kind of
want to do less and just be better at
those fewer things so I'm now do it well
Bobby I would say
for reasons that I won't get into now
I'm kayak Barbie
that sounds incredible yeah I want a
bike I will say this Barbie is on track
Barbie
that's it I'm just focused in it in a
new different way and not worried about
other directions let me just
kind of linear in a good way
wow and I still don't have an answer no
I feel like well the part the problem
well I'm not a Barbie I'm a human yeah
and so you know if I guess I would be um
well we're all Barbie yeah I think the
like
I guess the Barbie that maybe the the
goal before was like be like everything
to everyone Barbie and now the goal is
like be everything to myself Barbie I
love that I think you're in America
Barbie I'm an American I'm I'm a Barbie
America
not the country yeah yeah it's funny
because Barbie has always been how we've
all seen ourselves and you guys have
allowed so many people in our world not
in Barbie land to see themselves I mean
Margo it's because of you and your
production company Lucky chap that we're
even hearing your commitment to like
telling female focused stories you say
you've literally shifted culture and
entertainment you're always hiring
people of color and film and TV Kate you
were the first openly gay female on SNL
like America is a Latina like you have
been everything to me like you've always
represented us SI SE pueda is like such
a mantra of mine from your movie gotta
kick it up so really I just wanted to
say thank you guys so much for
everything you do inside outside of
Barbie land you guys are the best and
thank you guys so much for watching
tickets to Barbie are on sale right now
on fandango.com my name is as Perez and
sometimes I call myself TV host Barbie
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
all the attributes